well luckily we actually will have one
of the top players with us here is with
us so maybe he can discuss that position
as well levonne you finished uh your
first game in the U.S chess champion uh
ship uh in a drop quite a quick draw
tell us a bit about that
um yeah we got this variation uh that uh
I've played with white and black and I
think I knew it a bit more than my
parents and I knew that this Knight A5
idea is important
otherwise blood can be slightly worse
after A3 Bishop B7 Bishop to C2 Knight
to A5 yeah uh describe to us the details
of this movement so the point is if you
just like make a pass instead of 95
proxy yeah Queen D3 comes and it's quite
unpleasant because you have to commit
already with G6 Bishop H6
and uh rookie 8 Rook 81
it's uh it's playable for black but
I think it's easier for white to play
because
he has attacking ideas here and why does
Knight A5 change things in the position
why can white just play a queen yeah he
can but then you can take on F3 and take
on D4 so you would pick up the pawn
and it seems it works because Queen lc4
is protected yeah so
E3 Queen to C4 or even Queen to G4 in
this case I think it's Bishop F4 the
move here of course there's a
compensation provided the queen C4 I
think
it's not too scary for black so he
definitely felt like you were aware of
what to do in the position you had this
in your preparation did you feel like
your opponent was pondering potentially
continuing the game at any point
oh
I guess
he plays a line that is
considered to be a combative line so I
guess he's not willing to make a quick
draw or repetition but I think he
understood that I know this position
better than him so that's why maybe he
decided to settle for a draw you've
played so many top Elite level events
throughout your career but this is your
first US championships do you have any
butterflies
ah it's wonderful you know that this you
know it's like old-fashioned 14 players
I really love this and there is this
kind of uh you know feeling like as the
French say
espritical you know that everybody is
here for one purpose and it's it's one
big family of chess players I really
love that it's a Well national title on
the line so definitely a big event now
let's talk about this game you guys were
mentioning this one between Sam and Ray
Robson how do you assess this one
it's a well-known line and this is the
old-fashioned way of playing with black
I think kramnik played like this with
black but he tried to play 90 f8 96
early on I think on move 10 line is F6
Knight F3
and then I think Knight f8 something
like this but the general consensus
consensus of this variation is that
although the computer is fine he thinks
black is okay but it's much easier to
play with white I mean at least that's
what
um
I think and that's what I think some of
my colleagues think what are the plans
for both sides I think white normally
puts the queen on C3 early on maybe even
before
maybe here something like that and then
you try to play C4 you know okay four or
K1
and queen A3 eventually and take on A6
and check sacrifice
that's pretty straightforward yeah yeah
just to exemplify it let's put a couple
of moves because it's quite a risk
and of course I'm making very bad moves
for it black obviously but this is quite
nice Rook takes A6 take on A6 Queen
takes A6 yeah you know in this position
you want to intimidate black into taking
only three and then once you you take ft
key
then let's say here Bishop takes yeah
yeah you can take I mean maybe not here
because the pawn is not on before yet
maybe here we will capture with a knife
but if you were
g8b4 yeah yeah I think you take you can
take ft key and Knight A5 is coming
I mean there's always some sacrifices
yeah yeah you're trying to get this uh
you know even 985 93 95 this type of
ideas and it doesn't seem like black can
break through on the Kings No No it's
it's a rather passive position for black
so I
I think Ray uh maybe didn't expect this
opening so he he tries to play something
uh very solid
um but it's not the type of solid that I
like myself and how would black uh go
along and try to defend this position or
at least try to create let's say his
counter chances on the king side I think
he has to at some point go for F5 I mean
he has to play some Rook g84
you know and then try to play F5 and
kind of you know use this H3 G3 you know
E4 and try to get the queen involved in
the game
excellent well thank you very much uh
Levon and just to not to interrupt you
but this game has finished in a draw
between a wonder and Wesley saw
Levon uh congratulations on a successful
start to the US Championship you still
have plenty of games left we'll see you
in the future rounds thank you and Lavon
I don't want to put too much pressure on
you but you are my choice to win the
event so just yes
he's not trying to put too much pressure
I will not disappoint you yes sir thank
you that's what I wanted to hear that's
what I wanted to hear uh turning our
attention quickly uh to the game between
Bobby and Lanier for